Traduttore: Sara Fazzini
Revisore: Fatbardha Hoxha
How many roads
must a man walk down
before you call him a man?
How many seas
must a white dove sail
before she sleeps
in the sand?
How many times
must the cannonballs fly
before they're forever banned?
The answer, my friend,
is blowin' in the wind,
the answer is blowin' in the wind.
How many times
must a man look up
before he can see
the sky?
How many ears
must one man have
before he can hear people cry?
"How many ears
must one man have?"
"Quante orecchie deve avere un uomo
prima di sentire gli altri che piangono?"
Su questo verso mi sono sempre fermato,
cantando "Blowin' in the Wind".
Credo che si fermasse bene anche lui,
quando la cantava.
Quante orecchie abbiamo,
quante orecchie dobbiamo avere?
"Se gli dei ci hanno dato due orecchie",
diceva un filosofo,
"e una bocca sola,
forse una ragione
ce l'avevano".
E invece noi
pensiamo che
--sì, ci alleniamo per parlare,
per scrivere--
vi assicuro che tutti gli speaker
che ascolterete qua,
ci siamo impegnati.
E invece pensiamo che per ascoltare
basti stare lì.
"Ascolto" è una parola impegnativa,
è una parola difficile.
Per ascoltare bisogna concentrarsi, impegnarsi,
sollevarsi, un po' come volare,
bisogna sollevarsi, bisogna spostarsi,
bisogna andare da un'altra parte,
bisogna voler cambiare.
Siccome 'ascolto' è una parola di 7 lettere,
come vedete dai puntini,
forse intuite che
sto per costruirci su un gioco di parole.
Da un linguista
questo ci si può aspettare.
Sette
suggerimenti che voglio proporvi
saranno scanditi dalle 7 lettere
di questa parola
per ascoltare in modo efficace.
Il primo.
A:
Ascolta per ascoltare,
e non per rispondere o per giudicare.
Beh, pensate all'evento Bob Dylan;
so che iniziare con Bob Dylan
non è la cosa più popolare,
di questi tempi,
però qualcuno gliel'ha chiesto?
Qual è la sua posizione?
Gliel'ha chiesto
perché si è comportato così?
No, siamo stati,
dopo i primi momenti di latitanza,
prontissimi ad attaccarci un'etichetta:
prepotente, arrogante,
chi si crede di essere?
Poi, quando ha dichiarato:
"No grazie, scusate, molto gentili,
quel giorno lì ho da fare",
si sono scatenate polemiche:
"Ho da fare" si dice quando
ti invitano per il raduno
dei compagni di liceo, no?
Dicevo: "Ho da fare..."
Non si fa così.
Magari si sente inadeguato.
Non lo so, però
non gliel'abbiamo chiesto,
e questo è quello che facciamo
di solito.
Noi ascoltiamo
pochissimo.
Ascoltiamo quel tanto che serve
per metterci un'etichetta.
Credo che lo stiate facendo anche voi,
lo facciamo tutti.
"Ah, quello lì com'è vestito!"
"Ah, cosa c'entra la chitarrina?"
"Ah, 'sta parlata milanese!"
"Oh, ero capace anch'io!"
Ecco, qualunque
cosa accada qui,
velocissimi siamo
nel metterci un'etichetta.
Oppure,
ascoltiamo quel tanto che ci serve
per rispondere.
Pensate a una riunione di lavoro.
Parla uno, parla l'altro,
parla l'altra.
A un certo punto mi parte l'embolo
e io comincio a preparare
la mia risposta,
non ascolto più gli altri.
O a una conferenza, quando dicono
"Poi ci sarà spazio per le domande".
Io preparo la mia domanda
e non ascolto quello che dicono.
Ascoltare per ascoltare, e basta,
è il primo allenamento.
Che vi propongo.
Poi c'è la S di Ascolto:
ascoltiamo Solo parole?
Ci sono un sacco di altri elementi che
ci possono aiutare nell'ascolto.
Sono tre i canali attraverso i quali noi
esprimiamo quello che abbiamo dentro.
Le parole:
congiuntivi, verbi, nomi e aggettivi.
Poi abbiamo tutta la parte fonetica,
prosodica,
dicono quelli che parlano bene.
I suoni,
il timbro della voce, il tono della voce.
Se hai un timbro
come Gassmann, come Proietti,
come Lilli Gruber,
sei avvantaggiato.
Se ce l'hai come
la Iervolino,
sei un po' più in difficoltà.
Mario Giordano:
con quella voce lì
bisogna impegnarsi, tanto.
Però se io ho una voce alla Gassmann
e comincio a parlare con questo tono
vado avanti 10 minuti--
dormi anche con lui!
Quindi in certi punti bisogna andare
molto in su e in altri punti molto in giù.
In certi momenti bisogna accelerare
per concentrare l'attenzione
e in altri momenti le persone rallentano.
In certi momenti si fanno
delle pause.
Pensate che buco nello stomaco,
quando sei davanti a un medico
che sfoglia le tue analisi
e a un certo punto--
Comincia a partirti
un'ansia!
Se avete una persona che amate,
e anche nelle relazioni interpersonali,
potreste fare un esperimento
sull'effetto di una pausa.
Potreste prenderla,
a bruciapelo, senza avviso,
scuoterla e dirle:
"Dimmi la verità! Dimmi la verità!
Mi ami?"
E questo--
"Sì!"
Ecco, quando uscirà
la parola che ti aspettavi,
che cosa che è girato dentro?
E poi c'è tutta la parte fisica, no?
L'abito, il sorriso, la postura.
Pensate ai gesti.
Ss io vi dicessi adesso:
"Abbiamo una grande opportunità".
Cioè vi dico la parola "grande"
e con le mani faccio un gesto piccolo,
quanto vi eccita?
"Sono molto felice
di essere qui oggi a TED".
Non ci credete!
Se vi dico "Sono molto felice!",
potete crederci.
Allora il secondo allenamento:
ascoltiamo le parole e ascoltiamo
un sacco di altri elementi
che stanno intorno.
La C, 'Certe' parole.
È opportuno ascoltare in particolare
certe parole: quali sono?
Abbiamo un'infinità di parole
nelle nostre lingue.
185.000 sono circa
le parole dei dizionari,
quelli alti così.
465.000, il dizionario più ricco:
sono 7 volumi, o 6, non ricordo bene.
Perché contiene queste,
più le parole dei cosiddetti
DIS, dizionari italiani speciali,
quelli di settore.
Il medico, il giuridico,
l'assicurativo, il bancario, lo sportivo.
Pensate a come parlano gli informatici:
Zippalo, droppalo, backuppalo,
downloadalo.
Tu lo downloadi, lo printi,
lo flagghi, lo ri-uploadi e lo forwardi.
Tra di loro si parlano perfettamente,
si capiscono.
Pensate che disastro avviene
se io dico una parola in un mio DIS
e tu la leggi nel tuo DIS.
Non so, 'premio'.
Io intendevo la coppa
perché sono uno sportivo
tu intendevi il pagamento della polizza.
Positivo e negativo qui dentro
vogliono dire quello che dicono:
"Com'è andato il TED? Molto positivo!"
Eh, sarete contenti!
In fondo a un'analisi medica
non sono sfumature,
è il contrario.
Settimana prossima, se voteremo, voteremo
sì per dire sì e no per dire no,
ed è un'eccezione,
perché di solito i referendum
fanno il contrario.
Allora, di questa infinita mole di parole
con un sacco di ambiguità,
noi circa ne abbiamo 250,
che sono chiamate le nostre "hot words",
le parole che ci scaldano il cuore.
E di queste una cinquantina sono
chiamate le nostre "key words",
le parole chiave,
quelle che il cuore ce lo aprono
o ce lo chiudono.
Se c'è qualcuno di voi
che si chiama Alessandro come me,
quando ci presentiamo,
vi sarà capitato: "Alessandro. Anch'io!"
Però la prima roba che ti arriva in testa
sei tu, o come i tuoi figli,
come le persone che ami.
Se riuscissi a vedere alcune teste
canute tra di voi, saprei che per esempio
la parola "Fornero" ad alcuni di voi
magari cambia la temperatura.
Allora, quanto è utile quando io ascolto
una persona riconoscere le parole
che danno
energia, vigore:
amore,
salute,
onore, libertà.
Le parole sulle quali le persone
mettono enfasi.
Riconosciamole e trattiamole
con la massima cura.
O:
"O" è una parola che genera un bivio.
Mangi questo o mangi quello?
Preferisci stare qui o andare altrove?
Congiunzione disgiuntiva.
Siamo sicuri
che quando ascoltiamo un racconto,
di qualcuno,
ascoltiamo il racconto?
Oppure lo ascoltiamo
nella nostra percezione,
nei nostri pregiudizi,
nella nostra rappresentazione.
Mettete qui
una cosa, qui un'altra
e qui un'altra ancora.
Qui ci sono i fatti della vita.
Una partita di calcio, una guerra,
un atto d'amore.
Qui c'è la mia percezione,
e qui c'è quello
che vado in giro a dire sul tema.
C'è gente che confonde questi tre piani.
C'è gente che pensa di pensare sempre
il vero, di avere la verità in tasca.
Gente che pensa di dire il vero.
C'è gente che pensa di dire
sempre ciò che pensa.
Conoscete molta gente che dice:
"Ah io non ho peli sulla lingua,
dico tutto quello penso".
Se sei così vattene
su un'isola del Pacifico,
butta via le chiavi
e non far danni in giro!
Cioè, quando avevi sei mesi
potevi dire tutto ciò che pensavi.
Pensate ai bambini di 6 mesi,
finita la pappa
vengono presi,
messi sulla spalla, coccolati
e la mamma
gli dà delle pacchette,
acciocché il bambino
manifesti al mondo
la sua felicità.
E quando la manifesta la mamma
lo prende: "Amore mio, tesorino".
Quando ha 14 anni,
quel cristo lì,
dovrebbe aver filtrato
che tra ciò che si sente
e ciò che si dice o si manifesta--
Allora, distinguiamo la realtà
dal pensiero sulla realtà,
dalla rappresentazione linguistica.
E mettiamoci
le nostre tare.
L sta per Logica, strutture logiche.
Cos'è l'analisi logica?
È l'analisi delle sequenze
delle parole dentro una frase.
Un giorno, in un convento,
un novizio chiese al suo priore:
"Padre, posso fumare mentre prego?"
E fu rimproverato, castigato
come il peggiore dei peccatori.
Un minuto dopo, un altro novizio
chiese allo stesso priore:
"Padre, posso pregare mentre fumo?"
E fu lodato per la sua devozione.
Ora, la storiella vi sembrerà
anche stupidina,
ma fumare mentre prego
e pregare mentre fumo
è la stessa roba, è la stessa cosa.
La differenza
sta nella percezione dell'altro.
Ci sono persone che prima di raccontarti
una cosa devono farti le premesse.
Quelli che dicono:
"Guarda, ti devo dire una cosa
ma prima devo farti una premessa".
No, la premessa no!
Dimmi la cosa!
O viceversa, quelli che te la sbattono
sul muso e tu avevi bisogno
delle cause
che hanno generato quell'effetto.
Se un medico dice a un paziente:
"Signor Mario, o Giovanni,
la situazione è piuttosto grave,
ma per fortuna l'abbiam presa in tempo
e siamo ottimisti per il futuro".
Oppure dice: "Per fortuna l'abbiamo presa
in tempo e siamo ottimisti,
ma la situazione è piuttosto grave".
È o non è la stessa realtà? Sì.
Quello che cambia è la percezione;
allora, le sequenze logiche,
causa ed effetto, effetto e causa,
passato, presente, futuro,
futuro, passato, presente,
sono il significato che le persone danno
a ciò che hanno da dire.
Ascoltiamole, senza giudicare,
riconosciamole e apprezziamole.
Penultimo allenamento:
ascolta anche Tra le parole.
La T sta per Tra e anche per Trans,
che vuol dire:
oltre.
Tra e oltre, le parole.
Per esempio,
in questo sono fantastiche le mamme,
le mamme sono cintura nera
del 'leggere tra le parole'.
"Com'è andata a scuola, oggi?"
"Ehm.."
Ecco, da quel "Ehm.."
la mamma comincia a scavare.
"Ehm" nel senso che ti ha segato,
"Ehm" nel senso che l'hai saltata,
nel senso che non c'era il prof.
Però le mamme sono mosse dall'amore,
nel fare un'indagine.
Lo fanno anche gli investigatori,
con sistemi poliziotti,
con sistemi un po' più coercitivi,
lo fanno gli psicoanalisti.
Andare tra
e sotto le parole, per ascoltare,
aiutando la persona che parla,
magari facendo delle buone domande.
Per esempio: "Sono spaventato".
Da cosa sei spaventato?
Da quando sei spaventato?
Come sei spaventato?
In che modo?
Dove hai sentito che eri spaventato?
La domanda
"perchè?"
non sempre è una buona domanda.
"Non voglio venire fuori con voi".
"Perché?"
"Perché no!"
La domanda "perché?" spesso genera
una chiusura, invece girandole intorno
si riesce ad andare sotto,
dentro, intorno alle parole
e far venir fuori
qualcosa di più significativo.
E l'ultimo punto,
la "O" di Ascolto vi richiede
una cosa un po' strana,
vi chiedo di mettervi
in fondo a questa frase
e leggerla al contrario,
come si fa di solito quando si atterra
in un volo.
Si pensa: "Quanta strada ho fatto,
da dove son partito".
Leggetela al contrario:
"Once upon a time".
"C'era una volta".
"Il y était une fois".
"Había una vez".
Tutte le favole iniziano
con questa formula,
che è la narrazione delle narrazioni;
le favole sono le storie per eccellenza.
E la gente racconta storie.
Ascoltiamo i racconti
delle persone, che non sono solo i fatti,
sono il valore che le persone
attribuiscono a quel fatto.
Se io dovessi raccontarvi
qualcosa su questa penna, vi direi
che è di plastica, ha un po' di metallo,
però vi direi il fatto.
Se vi raccontassi
che cosa rappresenta per me,
dal fatto che io la tenga qui
e non nel mio astuccio,
un'idea può venirvi.
È il valore, la persona che me l'ha
regalata, il significato che attribuisco.
Le persone non fanno l'amore
o la guerra per i fatti.
Fanno l'amore, la guerra, per
il significato che attribuiscono ai fatti.
E quindi
ci sono persone che ti raccontano
la visita che hanno fatto dal medico
o il film o il TED che hanno visto
e persone che ti racconto
le storie che vorranno
vivere in futuro.
"I have a dream".
Martin Luther King ha raccontato
sotto forma di sogno,
cioè una storia al passato,
un obiettivo,
sapersi muovere tra passato e futuro
è il valore
delle narrazioni.
Ascoltiamo con amore
i racconti delle persone,
perché è veramente
il maggior atto d'amore che possiamo
rivolgere a una persona,
ascoltare le loro storie.
E siccome ho la sensazione
che mi abbiate ascoltato,
lasciate che vi risponda.
Grazie.